these bananas are up to their nexon ash
from the nearby volcano
the greenhouse meant to protect them
collapsed
now
farmers have been given a moment of
respite
the volcano has been quiet for the third
day in a row
we're now digging holes to clear out the
ash
i don't even have the words to know how
much it's a lot this is more than 20
centimeters of ash
this has been the longest eruption in la
palma's history
but after three months the volcano is
finally showing signs of quieting down
according to spain's national geographic
institute
seismic activity has been weak with no
lava flow and only sporadic gushes of
smoke
in
it's a great feeling that the volcano is
silent for a third day
for me it's a joy and a message to the
island to keep going that this is just
beginning and together we can get up
again quickly
volcanic activity has to stay this quiet
for 10 days
only then can scientists say the
eruption is officially over
only then can residents begin to rebuild
what was lost without fearing the
volcano